[Music]
welcome back so we're using the SVD to
compute this eigen face representation
of human faces of pictures of human
faces that have been arranged into
column vectors of a matrix X so we have
a bunch of pictures of people's faces
2,400 of them as columns of X each of
these little 2d images have been
reshaped into a very tall skinny vector
with 32,000 dimensions and we've used
the SVD to find an orthogonal basis an
orthonormal basis of eigenfaces that you
can then add up a linear combination of
to reconstruct human faces so this is a
more compact representation potentially
or at least a different representation
of the structure of information in human
faces and so we just discussed that you
can take a new image X and you can
multiply it by your basis you are the
first are columns of your basis
transposed and what you get out is this
little vector this little R dimensional
vector alpha and alpha is essentially
like a fingerprint or a mixture an eigen
mixture of those eigen faces that you
would need to add up to get that
person's face back now it's really cool
is that you can actually use this for
image classification you can use the
information in alpha to tell if two
people are the same if two pictures of a
person are the same person or a
different person okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to multiply I'm going to
take two peoples images I'm going to
multiply them into this space and I'm
gonna plot where those points live in
these alpha coordinates okay that's
gonna be pretty pretty neat and this is
actually you know at least morally kind
of the basis of what is done in image
sciences like you know if facebook wants
to tell if this is person a or person B
you could in principle use this
technique so now they use a neural
networks for this but but in principle
you could use I can face classifiers or
you could classify in these eigen face
coordinates so I'm gonna just pull two
people from the from the database I'm
going to pick person two and person
seven just two people I'm gonna take the
whole library of all their faces
subtract off the average face remember
because we
I mean centering our data and then what
I'm going to do is I'm going to project
into the sixth and seventh eigen face
direction I'm sorry the fifth and sixth
eigen face direction I'm going to
project on the principal component five
and six so I'm literally gonna pull the
fifth and the sixth column of U and
that's going to be where I'm going to
project those images into those
coordinates and I'm gonna plot all of
person two and all of person seven in
those two coordinates the PC a five and
PC a six coordinates okay pretty simple
I literally just compute like PCA chords
one and two of these people and then I
plot them based on which person it is
and what you can see this is pretty
remarkable let me just make these a
little bit bigger okay so this is a
picture of the different people so
person 1 and person 2 are 2 & 7 whatever
these are the two different people that
I'm trying to tell apart and when I take
all of their images so there's 64 in
each of these people's images if I take
all of those images and I project it
into principal component 5 and principal
components 6 this is how the data falls
out and this is really remarkable what
you can see is that this is strongly
clustered all of this person are in
these white diamonds up here and all the
second person are in these blue
triangles down here and essentially the
because there's such clean separation I
could define a classification algorithm
so if I had a new picture of this person
if the picture embeds up here I know
exactly which person it belongs to it
belongs to person one who has these
white diamonds and if the picture ends
up embedding down here it belongs to
person two who belongs to these blue
triangles so you can use this for image
classification and this is super simple
this is just two principal components
two of these columns of you I get
extremely clean classification accuracy
I could probably get almost 99%
accuracy building a classifier in this
space okay for these two people that's
pretty remarkable now let's say that
instead of doing these two principal
components I did instead of modes 5 & 6
let's say I did principal components 1 &
2
right because those are even more
energetic maybe my data separates even
better in principle component 1 & 2 if I
run this it's pretty interesting these
points actually don't separate nearly as
well they're all mixed up and all over
the place and this is a really important
point is that in I in phases the first
few eigenvectors the first few
eigenfaces u 1 u 2 u 3 generally
speaking those capture all of the
features that are common to all people
all people have eyes and nose and mouths
and have kind of an oval face and then
principal components 4 & 5 & 6 start to
give you the features that actually
differentiate people maybe I have more
eyebrows than another person or maybe
another person's nose is a little you
know longer or shorter those get encoded
in the higher-order modes that have
lower energy because there's a lot of
energy and the features that all of us
have principal components 1 2 & 3
capture a lot of the variance of the
data but that's what makes us all the
same principle components 4 or 5 & 6 are
more the features that make us all
different okay and so that's why you get
such nice image classification and
separation when you plot in these higher
principle component 5 & 6 space ok so
pretty interesting and you can actually
use this for for classification okay so
in another lecture I'll show you how to
do this for superheroes so it's kind of
a fun example where instead of these
Yale faces we're gonna use pictures of
action heroes okay thank you